the conservative state of Texas is
becoming a major focal point ahead of
next month's midterm elections incumbent
Republican senator Ted Cruz won his seat
by almost 16 percentage points in 2012
but recent polls show a rising
Democratic star congressman bado
O'Rourke is within single digits
despite this chase the state's changing
demographics are Roarke will need strong
support from Latinos and young voters to
be Cruz we travel to Texas to meet both
candidates for interviews you'll see
only on CBS this morning you should be
free to make the decisions of what to do
in your life for Republican senator Ted
Cruz winning re-election in the deeply
read state of Texas should be easy
we're being out raised three to one but
Cruz now finds himself in a tight race
against Democrat Beto O'Rourke who's
trying to turn the state blue for the
first time in more than two decades a
Democrat hasn't won a statewide race
since 1994 why now I think at this
moment it's not about Democrats or
Republicans or party politics or the
differences that have always seemed to
define us it's about this country coming
together around the things that we care
most about at this moment of truth we're
either going to be a country of walls
Muslim bands and the press as the enemy
of the people or instead we'll be
defined by our ambitions why is this
race as opposed as it is
at the end of the day we're gonna win
this race the reason that we have a
competitive race is it is clear that the
hard left the extreme left in this
country that they're angry many of them
are filled with hatred for President
Trump and it colors everything else the
two couldn't be further apart on key
issues
O'Rourke is trying to sell a progressive
agenda including stricter gun
restrictions universal health care and
abortion rights Cruz says he's more
aligned with Texans on multiple fronts
including border security and strong
Second Amendment protections Texans want
lower taxes we want lower regulations we
want more jobs higher wages and more
opportunity we want to secure the border
those are the common-sense values that
bring Texans together whether it's
freeing dreamers from any fear of
deportation by making them US citizens
or bring in Republicans and Democrats
together to ensure their immigration
laws reflect our values and our written
in our own image those are things that
Texans of all walks of life and
background want us to lead on want us to
work together on this country before
running for Senate O'Rourke was a
punk-rock bassist who also ran a
software company before being elected to
three terms in Congress representing El
Paso his profile spiked last year when
he live-streamed an impromptu
cross-country road trip turned Town Hall
with Republican colleague we'll heard
his campaign has broken all conventional
rules not only have we been in every one
of the 254 counties of Texas we've
accepted no help from political action
committees special interests or or
corporations all people all the time
senator Cruz is a conservative icon the
married father of two was the star of
the failed 2013 government shutdown on
Obamacare and the Republican that came
closest to beating President Trump in
the 2016 primaries a fight that turned
personal lyin Ted Cruz we no lie attack
a lot of people wonder why doesn't that
seem to bother you more than
what anybody else you know I will say it
the media sadly is obsessed with
personality is obsessed with Trump
derangement senator
listen we had a vigorous primary vote
there haunted it was hard fun but it's
over and when the president was elected
I made a choice I made a choice for the
people of Texas I can either choose to
have hurt feelings and say all right
it's all about me I'm gonna be selfish
and so I'm going to take my marbles and
go home or I could choose to do my job
which is represent 28 million Texans and
work with the president work
cooperatively to get real solutions for
real problems for those people who are
on the fence they're concerned that you
may not work with him if you're elected
senator would you work with the
President on any policy absolutely
I'll find every possible way took to
work with anyone including President
Trump as we have done in the past to
advance this country's agenda and to do
better for for the people that I serve
look there's no denying that that a
Roark has really energized the
Democratic base there was a fundraiser
forum 55,000 people turned out at a
Willie Nelson concert on Saturday the
largest for a campaign since 2016 on the
other hand when I was with Ted Cruz
yesterday there were voters and
supporters who said you know what I
heard them speaking amongst themselves
saying I don't really like what the
president's been saying about Cavan or
what have you my business is doing very
well and this economy is doing very well
so we're gonna keep things as is and
vote for Ted Cruz so we'll see what ends
up happening maybe today almost here
yeah